Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the "Slow Mo Guys"
and as you may know,
we are huge gamers
aren't we Dan?
Big time, absolutely, yeah.
I'm a professional gamer.
In fact--
No, no, shut up.
What do you mean?
You can't have it that
you're professional gamer,
you're terrible, you're rubbish.
Technically, if you're paid to play games,
you're a professional.
No, no, you're misleading.
Well, I'm taking it.
Shut up.
Well, we're both very
excited for the release of
"Far Cry Primal".
And in this game, there's mammoths.
Yeah, mammoths, check it out.
So we've had big budget
increase in "Slow Mo Guys".
Bloody big .
Yeah, hired some scientists.
They've reanimated a mammoth for us.
True.
He's real.
Cool Clive.
All right Clive,
how's the going?
Yeah all right--
Chill.
Chill out Clive.
So.
So what are mammoth good for?
Crushing, obviously.
Crushing stuff.
Yeah.
So we're gonna
fire up the Phantom,
turn on a bright light and have Clive here
stomp some items down.
Hopefully it looked
pretty good in slow mo.
Let's do it.
Alright, so Clive's crushing
power is pretty forceful.
So we're gonna shoot this
at 2000 frames per second
on the Phantom Flex4K
and now we've got a nice,
big lovely light here.
Which allows us to film indoors.
'Cause it need a lot of light for slow mo.
Dan, I heard mammoth hate TV, is true?
Yes I mean, there was
obviously a lot of TVs
around when mammoth were cut and about.
Yeah.
So they've got to
hit it above the edge.
There's nothing left to it .
That's Clive, turns out he
really doesn't like Christmas.
On one give it a
okay, three, two, one go.
All right what's this one.
This one is the ice
sculpture on the same .
Another thing I would save is Lego.
I mean, they don't really
have the finger dexterity
to build it so they get very bitter
and I decided to trash it.
See you later .
Is this some of the
tables stuck to the bottom
of the foot.
Yeah.
Those are some breeze blocks.
One.
So in the wild, mammoth
search and crush watermelons
and then eat them.
Damn good day's work, I think.
Yeah Clive's done a smashing job.
He has and I'm gonna pretend
I didn't hear that pun
awful.
Yeah,
so we've done with him.
We could probably put him down now.
Take him out back.
Yeah.
Chill, sorry.
Sorry, Clive, just kidding Clive.
Seriously though Ivory
is worth quite a lot.
Yeah you can't have a
mammoth walking around.
I know, I need a coat as well.
Be sure to check out "Far Cry Primal"
when it comes out on Feb
23rd on Xbox One, PS4 and PC.
Yeah watch the trailer.
The link in the description below.
You can feel free to follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to the channel,
buy a shirt or a poster.
There's plenty to do.
The world is your oyster at this point,
the world is your mammoth.
It doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't, it's not really.
Idiot.
A pun no?--
No, that was crap.
Don't do that again, leave it to me.
I'll let you do it the .
Yeah.
Hey big lad you want more watermelon?